>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Curtis Sandberg: Morning.
Morning. Welcome.
It's great, okay.
Welcome. I'm Dr. Curtis
Sandberg and I get
to have a couple
of minutes here.
I'm the Director of the David
M. Rubenstein National Center
for White House History
at the White House Historical
Association and I'm also --
I have this very long job title.
I'm also Senior Vice President
for Educational Resources
at the Association.
So it's History, it's
the Digital Library,
it's sort of all of our
content-driven material.
We're really delighted
-- we've been --
this has been, as you
can imagine, you know,
we've been working
on this forever,
so we're really delighted to
welcome you all to the summit.
It's, as you know, a
unique gathering of you
and you were presidential
leaders, site directors,
library directors, educational
specialists, area experts.
It's a really amazing gathering
and I think we're going
to have fun in the
next few days.
So we look forward to
connecting with you.
You know, we began talking,
some of us, in the lobby
at the Willard, but
we'll keep that going.
The idea of this is to create
a hub that you meet each other,
which you're doing, and you meet
us, and that we keep doing this
in the future, and it becomes
a gathering that, you know,
it has real teeth and it emerges
into something that's
[inaudible] for all of us.
Now our group envision,
and we -- in planning this,
several excursions
for attendees,
and so we're starting.
We're here.
And we have our friends at the
Library, a number of our friends
at the Library have been
absolutely instrumental
in creating this event, and
the Librarian of Congress,
Dr. Carla Hayden, we talked
with her months and months ago,
and she was very
keen about this.
We have Dr. Jane McAuliffe
who is the -- there we go.
Thank you.
So much better.
Okay, thanks.
And Dr. McAuliffe is
the Director of National
and International
Outreach at the Library.
And Jason Yasner --
Jason, you're back there
someplace or another?
There we go.
That's Jason Yasner
who has a new job.
Jason has been very instrumental
as well as the Deputy Director
of the National Library
Service for the Blind
and Physically Handicapped.
And Kimberly McCullough,
who a number of you met,
who is Library Special
Events Coordinator.
There are some treats
in store for us.
We have Cheryl Fox here
who's the Resident Curator
in the Library's Manuscript
Division, and she'll take us
around and give us the
insider's view of the Library.
So I'll close and welcome
you again to the Summit.
And it's not doing that awful
noise anymore which is great.
We're with you and being
excited about seeing new
and exciting things and being
part of the behind-the-scenes,
so I think, Jane, are you up?
So welcome Dr. Jane
McAuliffe please.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Well, good morning.
As Curtis said, I
am Jane McAuliffe.
I'm Director of National and
International Outreach here
at the Library of Congress.
That means I manage many
of the public-facing
activities of the Library.
And among my most pleasant
responsibilities is welcoming
distinguished guests like you
to the Library of Congress.
How many of you have
been here before,
have been to the Library
of Congress before?
Oh, good. Great.
Well, whether it's a
first or a return trip,
I really do hope this morning
will be an exciting experience
for you.
As you likely know, we have a
newish Librarian of Congress.
Dr. Carla Hayden is just
about to begin her
third year in that role.
And as Librarian, Dr. Hayden has
pledged to connect the Library
of Congress to people
across America.
We're doing this by enhancing
the visitor experience for those
of you who are actually able to
come to us here on Capital Hill,
but also by enriching
digital, digital connectivity
across the country
and across the world.
I know that you have gathered
from all over the United States.
So I hope that we can find
ways to stay connected with you
and to help you in the important
work that you are doing.
So I mentioned I'm
head of National
and International Outreach.
But another hat I wear is as
the Librarian's Representative
to the White House Historical
Association Board of Directors.
So I've had a chance to witness
close hand the wonderful work
that people like Stewart
McLaurin, the President
of the White House
Historical Association,
who's with us this morning,
and Curtis Sandberg,
whom you heard introduce
our session this morning.
And I have enjoyed seeing
collaborations develop
between the Association and the
Library of Congress in areas
as diverse as digital
resources, book promotion,
and merchandise development.
It's really a terrific team,
and I know they have
devoted every effort
to making this Presidential
Site Summit the best ever.
As I reviewed the final
program for this summit
over the weekend, I could
do nothing but marvel at all
that lies in store
for you this week.
But, of course, the very
best event is this kickoff
introduction to America's
Library.
So let's get started on
that and welcome Cheryl Fox,
the Library of Congress
Archive Specialist
in our Manuscript
Division to the podium.
Thanks for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> Cheryl Fox: Good morning.
I'm Cheryl Fox.
I am a curator within
the Manuscript Division.
There are lots and lots
and lots of collections
in the Manuscript Division,
and I'm here to tell you
about just one small
portion of them
which is called the LC Archives
which is the collective records
of the Library of Congress.
And I'm so happy to have
an opportunity to talk
to you this morning and talk
about the Library of Congress
and the White House's
shared history,
some of the collaborations
that we had in the past, and,
of course, looking forward
to many more in the future.
So the close ties between the
White House and the Library
of Congress started before
this city was occupied
as the Federal City because
they had to make arrangements
to move here and, of course,
there were not resources
like Philadelphia's
Library Company
in the Federal City
at that time.
And so President Adams provided,
in an act of 1800, for $5000
and a suitable apartment
within the Capitol
for the Library of Congress.
And there was a compromise
that had to be forged
to reach that consensus.
And the other part of
it is that they decided
that the President would
be in charge of nominating
or appointing, I should say,
the Librarian of Congress.
And so it remains.
And so this unique close
connection between the Library
and the White House was
established at that point.
So we all are aware that
Pierre L'Enfant's plan provided
for the Capitol and the
White House to be connected
by Pennsylvania Avenue, as
you see here, but separate,
to indicate their
separate status as branches
of the Federal Government
and, of course, we also know
that the Capitol in this time
period housed the Library
of Congress as well
as the Supreme Court.
So the U.S. Capitol, such as
it was back in the early days,
was just part of the wing,
part of one wing was there.
And the first two Librarians
of Congress were
simultaneously clerks
of the House of Representatives.
So they didn't really see it as
a full-time job at that point,
to be Librarian of Congress.
And, as you know, the
White House was similarly
in the process of being built.
But by the time they reached
the point of development
of the Capitol where
both wings were built,
along came the American
Revolution Part II, so to speak,
when the British burned the
Capitol and the White House.
The Library of Congress
collection was
completely destroyed.
Some things were managed to be
evacuated from the White House.
But, anyway, the
buildings were gone.
This was bad news.
But then, also, oddly enough,
very good news for the Library
of Congress because Thomas
Jefferson was available
to offer his private library for
sale to the Library of Congress.
And -- well, it's
Congress, I should say.
And this became the center,
the hear, of the Library
of Congress collection which
it remains to this day.
And it permanently changed the
Library of Congress as an entity
because it went from being
simply a reference collection
for the use of Congress
to a real library.
In fact, an outstanding
library that had materials
in many different languages.
It had bibles and religious
tracts in addition to law books.
It had history as well as
music and architecture.
And the very simple but
wonderful arrangement by memory,
reason, and imagination allowed
the Library, or even, in fact,
suggested to the Library to
develop in all directions,
not just simply, you
know, for Congress,
but for a comprehensive,
universal collection.
There was another fire, however.
And this one even really worse
than the first one to my mind
because it destroyed two-thirds
of President Jefferson's
Library.
This is a piece from
the newspaper
which was telegraphed --
reports from telegraphs
from the Capitol City that
the Library had burned
and that President Fillmore,
the Mayor, Speaker of the House,
and numerous members in
offices of Congress were early
on the ground rendering
all the aid in their power.
So this is an example
of one very direct way
that the White House helped
the Library was by trying
to save the collection.
Most of it was destroyed,
however.
And President Fillmore,
in addition to helping us fight
the fire, approved $5000 to --
for clean-up, $10,000
to replace the books,
and then an annual appropriation
to repair the deficiencies
caused
by the destruction
of the Library.
So the happy result was that
the Library got its own space
within the Capitol,
much larger space.
This illustration is called --
I called it The Iron Room
because it was, in fact,
the largest iron room, a room
made of iron, in the world.
And, of course, it was the --
the Architect was
Thomas E. Walter.
It was 91 feet in length,
34 feet wide, 38 feet high.
And a visitor to the Library,
British Scientist
Sir Charles Lyle,
wrote that it was the most
beautiful room in the world.
Maybe he was just trying
to say something friendly.
I'm not sure.
And in this time period, also,
there was still deliberation
over where the National
Library should be.
Should it be with the
Smithsonian or should it be
with the Congressional Library?
And at that time the
matter was settled.
And certainly it looks
the part, doesn't it?
And there are, as you see,
spectators and tourists
in addition to readers and
lots of things going on,
cultural activities, that
would come to be associated
with the Library of Congress.
And getting back to President
Fillmore just for one moment.
I would be remiss if I did not
note that he as the President,
and First Lady Fillmore,
who are credited
with establishing the
first White House Library.
It was not that Presidents prior
to that time didn't have
books in the White House.
They certainly did.
But this was an official
collection which, oddly enough,
wound up coming back to
the Library of Congress
as a special collection.
I'm not going to get
into all of that,
but there's a wonderful
book called,
The First White House
Library , and Catherine, Cath,
Catherine, I believe, Parisian
has written a wonderful,
wonderful book listing
the books that were
in the Library and its history.
So back to the bookish
presidents.
Our founders were men of
means who had great libraries.
Later presidents also were
very interested in reading.
And some presidents like
Garfield wrote in 1873 --
he was working on a speech in
his home at Cleveland, Ohio,
and he said, "Every
day I miss Spofford
and our great Library
of Congress."
Or, for example, when President
Roosevelt abruptly became
President of the United
States, he wrote to Mr. Putnam,
"As I leave, to put it mildly,
a sedentary life for the moment,
I would greatly like some books
that would suit my queer taste.
I do not supposed
there are any --
I do not suppose there are any"
-- excuse me one second here --
"there are any histories
of any articles upon the
Early Mediterranean races.
That man Lindsay, who wrote
about Prehistoric Greece,
has not put out a
second volume, has he?
Has a second volume of
Oman's Art of War appeared?
If so, send me both or either.
If not, then a good translation
of Meevor [assumed spelling]
and Mommsen," who were both
historians of Ancient Rome,
"or the best history
of Modern Mesopotamia.
Is there a good history
of Poland," he wonders.
And so you can see his eclectic
tastes there's this really
close relationship.
The relationship
predates his presidency.
When he was Secretary
of the Navy, Roosevelt,
Teddy Roosevelt would come
here to join the Librarian
and other invited
guests in the Attic,
which is where the cafeteria was
at that time, to join Librarian
of Congress Putnam's round
table as sort of a gathering
of intellectuals, visiting
dignitaries, diplomats,
what have you, and a few
chosen staff members.
Not all of them, certainly.
And if you look into the
Librarian's ceremonial office,
just down the hall,
you'll see the round table,
which is there on display.
So there were lots of
reasons for presidents
to love the Library of Congress.
And here you see T.R. again.
Another guest at the round
table was H.G. Wells.
He was lamenting being
in the United States
and not enjoying it at all.
And he visited the
Library in 1906 and wrote,
"I found at last a little
group of men who could talk.
It was like a small raft
upon a limitless sea.
I lunched with them
at their round table.
And afterwards Mr. Putnam
showed me the Rotunda."
And just to point out
the obvious there, again.
Once the Library occupied
this building, it became even
that much more of a tourist
attraction and people could look
into the Reading
Room, they could look
at the beautiful works of art.
Now not all the people in the
White House who used the Library
of Congress were presidents.
Members of the family
frequently borrowed books.
And so in -- as the archives,
there are registers
of borrowers.
And one of them is when Lincoln
was a member of the House
of Representatives, and
you see his page of books
that he borrowed, and
it includes these kind
of spicy romance novels in there
[laughter], and you think, well,
my goodness, is he
reading this before
or after he's reading
the Articles of War?
It turns out those were
borrowed by Mary Lincoln,
as people determined later.
But the members of the family
could certainly borrow books.
And this extraordinary
photograph --
I could not resist putting
it in here somewhere.
As you see, it's a Granafolo
[sic] which is an early machine
for playing records that
amplifies sound without the use
of the great big trumpet that
you see with the Victrola.
And, anyway, they were often
made to look like furniture,
and hers looks just
like a piano,
which I think is
kind of hilarious.
And there she is with the
disc that she's playing.
She didn't just play
music on her Granafolo,
she also played music
on the piano.
Unfortunately, she did not
always return the music
that she borrowed from
the Library of Congress,
and I know this because
the Chief
of the Music Division wrote
to Library of Congress Putnam
that they'd asked her several
times to return these things,
and she still had not done it.
And I guess they -- he
wanted the Librarian
to handle this somewhat
sticky situation.
First Lady Lou Henry Hoover --
I'm sure some of you will be
familiar with her reputation
as a scholar and as a person
who studied many languages,
Mandarin as well as Latin
and the Romance Languages.
And she had had a delivery
of her so-called Agricola's.
In other words, Incunabula
by George Agricola,
aka George Bower, that was
first published in 1556.
And she assured the
Librarian that 20 years ago,
when she was working
with these early volumes,
she would have been
able to decide
that herself in a few minutes.
But it has been so long since
she has read German script,
particularly German manuscript,
that it would take her a
very long time to do it now.
She is therefore imposing
on you and Mr. Martel.
She's referring to the Chief
Classifier at the Library
of Congress, Charles Martel, who
was born in Switzerland and came
to the United States and
became an excellent classifier,
but also retained his immense
knowledge of German language
and literature, and was able to
provide her with the information
that she needed on the
Agricola's as she called them.
Now, everybody knows Eleanor
Roosevelt had a separate career
and identify prior to
becoming First Lady.
She wrote the "My Day"
column from 1935 to 1962.
She had her own radio program
called Mrs. Roosevelt's Own
Radio Program .
And she wrote a column,
a monthly column,
in the Ladies Home
Journal beginning
in 1941, if you ask me.
And, of course, she travelled
around everywhere and spoke
to everybody who asked her to.
So she frequently
consulted with the Library.
She would forward letters
she had received in Braille
to the Library so that
they could be translated.
And she would ask sometimes
for help in remembering
where a certain quotation
came from.
She had this in her mind.
Maybe she wanted to write it in
a column or give it in a speech,
but who wrote this quote?
And some of them the
Library could answer.
Others -- maybe she
made them up.
Who knows?
The next Librarian of
Congress I'm going to talk
about was a friend and worked
with the Roosevelts prior
to their coming to the Library.
His name was Archibald McLeish.
And he had come to know the
Roosevelts during the campaign
for the White House.
He was at that time writing
for Fortune Magazine and had
already received a Pulitzer
Prize, one of three.
He was just here a short time.
A librarian/historian prior to
my time, called his tenure here
at the Library, the
brush of a comet.
It was brief and spectacular,
and you could see him here.
This is a clip, a Berryman
cartoon, of course,
and he's working for
the opposite facts
and figures while he's
Librarian of Congress
and he's shooting cannonballs,
I guess, at Fort Truman.
And so he was a known person,
not a shy, retiring librarian,
but a real public
figure in his own right.
And he accomplished so much
in such a short time
at the Library.
He oversaw the reorganization
of the Administration
and founded the Library of
Congress "Quarterly Journal
of Acquisitions," as well as
the "Information Bulletin,"
which is still in publication.
He really helped the Library
to gain a war footing.
He was an ardent defender
of democracy and thought
that libraries should be
the arsenal for democracy.
And here you see him with Lord
Lothian accepting the deposit,
temporary deposit, of a
copy of the Magna Carta .
Part of what he did in
war, preparation for war,
was to send the Magna
Carta and the Declaration
of Independence and The
Constitution to offsite
storage, Fort Knox.
And those were returned in 1945.
Also there were 29 truckloads
of so-called irreplaceable
material.
So they did this
great big 10,000 hours
of Library staff volunteer
time to assess the collections,
conserve them, list them,
box them, send them off-site
to Dennison University Ohio, and
in Virginia the VMI, Washington
and Lee College and
the University
of Virginia, excuse med.
And this is a cartoon marking
the return of these documents.
And there you see MacLeish.
"Easy, boys.
And watch those doors"
over The Declaration .
And be sure the glass
is good and clean ."
And you see The
Declaration returning,
and The Constitution .
And the caption is, "May they
never have to be hidden or kept
in the dark ever again."
And so you see the Library's
connection to winning the war
and re-establishing ourselves.
And certainly Archibald MacLeish
was very involved in that.
He wrote radio scripts.
He wrote -- gave presentations.
He wrote articles for
various publications
on democracy and things.
And so he was a very influential
person in the time period.
And here you see another one,
the Return of The
Declaration of Independence .
This and the other illustrations
are from our Prints
and Photographs Collection.
I just really admire that image.
And, of course, it
was used on the cover
of The New Yorker Magazine .
I hesitate -- this is kind of
a joke, but there was a point
in time in which
The Declaration
of Independence was stolen.
You see, Dr. VonMorgue had
hypnotized Little Abner
with his Z-Ray and influenced
him to buy a fake copy
of The Declaration of
Independence and to pick
up a rock and to enter the
Great Hall, smash the case,
replace it with the fake,
and make off with it.
Now, of course, he returned it
and everything was
fine after that.
I just thought, this is in 1938.
So it gives you the idea of
how well known these documents
in The Shrine in the Library
of Congress were at the time.
So I want to focus a
little bit of attention
on some more recent
collaborations having
to do with literacy.
And beginning with Barbara
Bush, she was already a champion
for literacy and
causes related prior
to coming to the White House.
But her first -- she took her
first meeting in the White House
with the Librarian of
Congress and the --
now the Library's
Historian, John Cole.
Then he was the Director
for the Center for the Book.
And within a month, as he
tells me, she was reading
to children in the Great Hall.
So this was really a natural
collaboration, but something
that had not been done before.
And it wound up into --
resulting in a number of
programs to further reading
and the cause of reading
and literacy beginning
with the Year of
the Young Reader.
And, as you know, this coming
Saturday is the Book Festival.
This is probably the most
successful collaboration the
White House and the
Library of Congress have had
because First Lady Laura Bush
brought the Book Festival
concept to the Library
of Congress.
It began in 2001 until 2014.
The Book Festival
was held on the Mall.
Now it's in the nice and cool
Walter E. Washington Convention
Center supported by
numerous public benefactors,
foundations, and corporations.
And in 2016, John Cole, who
I mentioned, was recognized
by the Bush Foundation as
a champion of literacy.
He has worked here at
the Library for 50 years.
He was the Founding Director of
the Library Center for the Book,
and founded programs for readers
of all ages, including Letters
About Literature, Books
and Beyond Authors Series,
the Ambassador for Young
People's Literature,
and recently opened the
Library's Young Readers Center.
And so I'm just recognizing him
and his valuable contribution
to us as a library,
the collaboration
with the White House,
and looking forward
to many more fruitful
collaborations in the future.
If anybody has any questions,
I'd be happy to try to answer.
Skimmed over that
pretty quickly.
Okay. Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.